with us Christmas in New York hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks a lot for taking my call sure
what's up I have a question I'd like to
get your opinion
I currently take out nine percent of my
paycheck and my company matches six
percent and they also recently I signed
up just at the bare minimum for they
offer an Employee Stock Purchase Plan
and it's a very very good stable company
big big orthopedic company so they're
gonna be around for a while and the the
the good deal is that it's 15% off of
what the public is I the stock it always
is all employee starting that plans are
exactly the same and and and I know from
listening to you that you personally do
not get involved as you say in
individual stacks but would you make an
exception in that regard no not at all
no the only way I would do it is after a
year up in the baby step past baby step
four are you debt free except your home
no no I owe about $1,200 just done on a
credit card then that's about it really
okay you need to get that cleaned up now
you have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses not yet no I'm
working on that we teach people not to
start investing until you've done those
two things and at that point I would
tell you to start putting 15% you put
15% of your income into retirement and
that's 401ks or Roth IRAs or Roth 401 KS
then on top of that it sounds like your
company's going to give you a match
which is wonderful and we recommend you
put that into four types of growth stock
mutual funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international and
I spread my personal 401k that way
across those with good track records
with long term track records that way
above that
when you start talking about buying a
house if you want to do some other
investing at some point and you want to
buy some single stocks and you want to
buy single stock in that company that's
fine that's fine but I don't want you
wouldn't I don't want you to do it
because it's such a great deal because
it's not that great a deal
15% office and not that great a deal and
I'll prove it to you
go pull your very big very stable
company up and look at the 52-week high
and the 52-week low you're probably
going to see a 15% move in the two and
so the discount that you got can
evaporate in about an eyeblink when
you're playing with single stocks and
say okay it's okay to do that but no
more than ten percent of your total net
worth needs to be in the single stock
and you know you're really not cheating
the system everybody that has an
employee stock option plan is 15% off
everybody does but the volatility will
make that go away in a heartbeat because
you're playing a single stock so it's
okay to do it but you need to have all
these other things done before you do it
and only then and then I would only have
no more than ten percent of your net
worth tied up in single stocks in one
company because here's what I ran into
many many many years ago Procter &
Gamble took a huge hit and I'm Anna's
probably this might have been twenty
five or thirty years ago
Procter & Gamble's a huge big stable
company but they went through a period
of time they took a huge hit and I sat
down with this long-term employee who
had worked for them for forty years and
this is where I learned one of the
places many times I saw this story and I
just decided I'm not gonna do this and
this lady the sweet lady had worked with
him forever she had seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in her 401k one
hundred percent of it in P&G stock and
it suddenly became more three hundred
that's what the that's what can happen
to you when you're playing a single
stock and you know you're not
diversified you've got everything tied
up in that she bet her whole
existence on Procter & Gamble
that's a dumb bad I'm not picking on
Procter and Gamble I don't care what
company fill-in-the-blank don't bet your
whole existence on one company that's
just dumb
you know don't have all your eggs in one
basket we say in the investing world so
that's why I say if you're gonna play
single stocks even your company single
stock even with a discount don't have
more than 10% of your net worth in there
because let's say she had $750,000 in
her 401k and 75,000 of it was in stock
and that went in half and that became
worth 37,000 she would have lost 37,000
out of 750 instead of half of her money
it substantially changed the quality of
her retirement because she was not
diversified she was stuck in this one
stock in arguably one of America's best
companies in arguably one of the most
stable companies that you can think of I
mean Procter & Gamble's not exactly a
volatile crazy world you know they're
not it's not exactly like a tech stock
or something this is not a startup for
God's sakes it's a huge monolith of a
company and to think that it would you
know just but they went through some
earnings issues back then and I have no
idea what their stocks doing now and I'm
not saying don't buy Procter & Gamble
nothing do probably that's not the point
the point is the story is a true story
and the sweet lady lost half of her
retirement because she violated the idea
of diversification and she had all of
her money in one place the Bible says in
Ecclesiastes spread your portions to 7
yes to 8 for disaster may come upon the
land